let's take you back to our top story
that just released pandora papers as
they're being called a collection of
nearly 12 million files published by the
international consortium of
investigative journalists now let's
recap what i said earlier it's exposing
a lot of offshore deals concerning all
kinds of world figures and leaders among
them the monarch of jordan close allies
of pakistan's prime minister and a
former british prime minister
let's get reaction out of europe with
rory challenge in a moment but first
let's speak to mike hanna in washington
dc mike let's start with the revelations
of what's being termed as a property
empire amassed by the jordanian monarch
in the u.s as well as the uk
yes indeed uh the papers report that
king ambala used shell companies to
obtain a number of properties in europe
in california in the u.s and indeed here
in washington d.c
property in georgetown it is alleged now
one must make very clear at the outset
here that no wrongdoing is being
attributed the king abdullah's lawyers
have already written to the publishers
of these documents making very clear
that there was no attempt to hide these
shell companies from public view uh
though of course there may be a domestic
impact within jordan itself given the
fact that these sums were being spent
while those within the country uh were
arguing about the economic situation uh
but the fact is that the king abdullah
did use shell companies according to the
papers to obtain a series of properties
in various parts of the world spending
money in excess of 100 million dollars
it is said i must state too as well that
these investigations have been compiled
over 18 months now the results are going
to be released on a daily basis focusing
on some of this massive trove of
documents now also mentioned in the
documents is the fact that the us is
becoming something of a tax haven that
points to south dakota for example where
uh tax laws have allowed a number of
international figures to secrete funds
once again uh there is no
wrongdoing necessarily alleged the fact
is that the facts of what is happening
are simply being pointed out in these
papers perhaps as more details follow we
will be able to follow up and see what
the precise nature of tax havens in a
state like south dakota is and what it
actually means for the biden
administration which has intended has
made very clear that it wants to stand
down on the use of offshore currencies
to avoid taxes uh here the possibility
that a u.s state may be used for
precisely that purpose and we've also
got a question about how damaging the
revelations might be for politicians in
pakistan take us through that mike
well there you've got a number of
politicians allegedly close to the
country's leader who once again have
used shell companies to put money into
various entities around the world now
once again this was according to the
papers conducted in secrecy i keep on
stressing though whether there was
wrongdoing involved or whether this is
tax avoidance rather than tax evasion
that is something for the courts to
decide uh but a large number of those
said to be close to the pakistani
leadership are involved in this but it's
not just limited to individual countries
uh the papers attribute uh such tax
activities among more than 35 heads of
state prime ministers kings uh
throughout the world ranging from the
leader of kenya to the leader of
azerbaijan so this is very widespread
throughout it also is going to provide
details on the uh tax avoidance or
evasion activities of more than 300
government leaders ministers and various
governments officials in various public
companies so this is a massive document
uh drop far greater even than the panama
papers from a few years ago certainly
far wider with far greater detail that
would appear then emerged in that
particular drop-off data which led to
the resignation of the number of
politicians around the world but just to
introduce another caveat that uh my
colleague in london is likely to pick up
on too for example you have former prime
minister tony blair and his wife details
are provided of a tax avoidance scheme
in which he saved some 300 000 pounds on
the purchase of a property belonging to
a bahraini politician now this was done
by avoiding stamp duties it is pointed
out in the papers that this is not an
illegal action however it points out too
that it's the type of tax avoidance
scheme that is not available to ordinary
citizens and requires a far greater
organization and far greater contacts to
be able to set it up but i must stress
as well the point being made here is
that this is not necessarily illegal it
may not look that good but it is not at
this stage criminally indictable and
there are many cases along these lines
in the papers that we have seen to date
but there's going to be much much more
detail revealed in the days weeks
possibly months to come
all right thanks so much that's mike
covering that end of this story let's
continue this with rory challenge in
london rory
might kind of segued us into the fact
that the uk at the center of
many of these revelations take us
through some of them
yeah well of many european names that
are going to be coming out of the
pandora papers there are a number of
prominent ones one of those is
president zielenski
of ukraine who interestingly when he was
campaigning to get that office he was
very critical of his predecessor petra
poroshenko an oligarch
and criticized him for
squirreling lots of money
in offshore accounts asset classes etc
taking that offshore um it appears that
zelensky
has been doing something not completely
dissimilar that together with a group of
associates friends from his former tv
days
he had been participating in
an offshore system that allowed him
not to declare various assets that he
had and he also it seems transferred a
25 stake in an offshore firm to one of
his friends mike was just talking there
about uh tony blair and cherie blair who
uh managed to
avoid paying uh
thousands of dollars worth of a property
tax when they bought a multi-uh
million pounds london building uh by
acquiring an offshore firm from the
british virgin islands now this
is not illegal but it shows you really
that if you have the money and the
connections you can find a way of
getting around attacks that most other
britons
have to pay as a matter of course
and i think the uk's role in all of this
is very difficult to understate
because
the uk has a huge number of lawyers
experts accountants etc
who are very very knowledgeable
excuse me about the offshore system and
are only too happy uh to take the money
of the world's wealthiest people to
allow them to hide their wealth
and that is something that the uk has
long been known for and these uh pandora
papers are putting again the spotlights
on the uk's financial services
and its and its property
and its property sector as a way for
lots of rich people around the world to
basically hide dodgy cash all right well
this is based on almost 12 million uh
documents so we'll let our guys go
through all of this now and we'll come
back to you later i'm sure there's a lot
more detail for us to pick up on rory
challenge there